[Music]
all right breaking news
pharmaceutical giant pfizer just
announced moments ago that its
coronavirus vaccine is
95 effective a second vaccine is now
on the horizon it could eventually free
us from this pandemic
developed in record time scientists
raced to free the world from the grasp
of covid19
but just as vaccines started rolling out
new threats emerged
casting a shadow of doubt there is a
realistic possibility
that this variant may be associated with
increased mortality
public health officials are trying to
contain an outbreak of one of the more
contagious
new variants they go by names like b117
b1351 and p1
what is becoming abundantly clear is
these new variants
are more infectious spread more easily
and can trigger
deadly outbreaks
virus mutation is normal but near the
end of 2020
southeast england became a hot spot for
a new coronavirus variant that started
to spread rapidly
it had 23 mutations
for scientists at the university of
cambridge in the uk
the search was on we didn't know that
you could find
viruses with so many mutations in one
virus
in the hunt for answers world-renowned
virologist ravi gupta has two roles
one in the lab at cambridge and the
other down the road and adam brooks
hospital
it was here he saw a cancer patient who
held important clues
the person was affected with the
coronavirus but because his immune
system was weakened by chemotherapy he
couldn't get rid of it
he was sick for more than a hundred days
allowing the virus to replicate
again and again we'd been learning for
a year that this virus didn't change it
was always the same there were a few
mutations here and there
and yet in this person we saw just the
most dramatic shifts you could imagine
a virus's strategy for survival is to
multiply by making copies of itself
but the copies aren't always identical
as sars cov2 replicates
small copying mistakes known as
mutations can happen
on average a strain if this particular
coronavirus can produce
one or two random mutations per month
some
have an advantage over others helping it
survive others don't
these mutations when combined with
natural selection
allow viruses to quickly adapt and
increase the likelihood of being passed
on to the next generation
while mutations that make the virus less
fit are likely
to die out in the case of the b117
variant found in the uk
many researchers believed that it
evolved within a single
immunocompromised patient
people with weakened immune systems can
have trouble fighting and killing the
virus
allowing it to continuously replicate
for weeks or months
generating more and more mutations it's
just a race against who can develop
quicker the virus or
us stephen kemp is a research associate
at university college london
he worked with gupta tracking the
evolution of the virus in that cancer
patient
who became chronically infected with the
coronavirus
he was then transferred to our hospital
where he stayed in our care for
about 100 days and what we did was over
those hundred days
at sequential time point we took various
different samples
and what we noticed was the patient was
developing a number of different
mutations
for example around day 66 after treating
the patient with two doses of
convalescent plasma
the virus's genetic structure started
shifting
it seems like after he'd received a
specific therapy which is called
convalescent plasma which is
plasma that's been taken from patients
who have defeated covid
when they're given to this patient it
seems that a number of mutations arose
but one of the mutations we found led us
to discover the b117 variant because
this mutation in our patient that had
emerged in response to treatment
actually was one of the key mutations
found in the b117
that key mutation is now known to make
the variant more
infectious there's not a whole lot of
evidence to suggest that it's
more deadly just that it's more
transmissible we were the first to
actually show that in vitro that these
mutations actually had a functional
impact
and therefore this was a sign that the
virus was not only evolving but actually
doing things to overcome
treatments that we were throwing at the
virus and this is the virus spike
protein here in
blue and it just shows the interaction
and how the virus is binding
so we went from looking at one patient
and then trying to understand how common
was this mutation
in coronaviruses from around the world
and that's where we found that there was
this big cluster of
hundreds of sequences from patients in
the uk that not only had our mutation of
interest
but had seven other spike mutations and
this was unprecedented to see
chronic infections are rare but there
are a growing number of cases around the
world
showing evidence of immunocompromised
covid19 patients
accelerating viral evolution i tested
positive for
like a total of nine times that's brutal
that's almost
like two months right of testing
positive and not going anywhere doing
groceries online not seeing anyone
literally just being in our house it was
the start of the pandemic
and ottawa resident brianne quarle
couldn't catch her breath
my youngest daughter had a birthday in
march and i was making her cake and
normally
i love to bake love to cook and i can do
it standing no problem
but i found myself taking breaks and
having to sit down to ice her cake and i
said to my husband i'm like oh thank god
i can sit down to do
this i'm so tired he was like well
that's weird
the mother of three decided to go to the
hospital and in a 24-hour span
coral went from needing an oxygen mask
to being intubated
she spent the next two weeks on a
ventilator
have you ever felt anything in your life
like you did
when you had covered 19 and that
struggle to breathe what was that like
no i've never felt anything that bad in
my life the struggle to breathe was
scary because
i've always had this irrational fear you
know of drowning or suffocating
so when i couldn't get my breath it felt
like that's what it would be like
to drown or to suffocate but coral's
health struggle started long before the
pandemic
in 2018 doctors found a brain tumor a
year later she was diagnosed with two
autoimmune disorders the 41 year old
falls into a category of people
who have a compromised immune system and
then
kovitt hit and that just sunk the boat
even further
immunocompromised people were not
included in the covid19 vaccine trials
so there's very little data on the risks
to them
it's currently unknown whether they'll
even be able to have an immune response
if they do get the shot what do we know
about what happens to them when they get
the vaccine
i think if you have an immune
compromising condition you are exactly
the population we want to get vaccinated
and i encourage you to do so
dr suman chakrabarti is an infectious
disease specialist at trillium health
partners in mississauga ontario
the really important thing if you look
at a place like israel is that we're
seeing
real world evidence that the vaccine is
very effective and this is a population
including young people
older people as well as people with
impaired immune systems
new research on variants of undercut but
not eliminated hope that covid19
injections
will end the pandemic a report released
in february suggested the pfizer buy in
tech vaccine
can still protect against new variants
but the company noted its shot is a
little less protective against the
variant in south africa
which may be able to escape antibodies
what is the research showing about how
effective these vaccines are
against the variants so if you look in
in certain kind of test tube experiments
you'll see that the variant from south
africa for example does have a reduced
response to the vaccines especially
astrazeneca but if you look more closely
you still have way more antibody than
you need to neutralize it so
while this might be something we see in
a chest tube clinically what we see
in person the person is still able to
clear the virus enough that they don't
get severe disease
and that's what i think is the most
important metric for us to look at
so taking a vaccine saves you from dying
which is the number one reason to
have a vaccine on a personal level so
that's fantastic news and that seems to
hold true
even for some of the more worrying
variants like the south african one
we are still seeing protection from
severe disease and mortality
moderna and pfizer are already working
on booster shots against the b1351
variant
so certainly if there are any additional
mutations which
will render the vaccines ineffective
then we'll have to
pull up our bootstraps and work a bit
faster
back in ottawa high-risk patients like
brienne coral
are worried while she says she will get
the vaccine when it becomes available to
her
there is a chance that she could get
infected with one of the new variants
while waiting it's a reality coral can't
afford to become true
it's been almost a year since she got
covid19 and
she's still suffering i still have
quite a few lingering effects to be
honest i still can't taste or smell
i lost most of my hair so this is
regrowth
i'm still not where i want to be i'm
better than where i was
but i'm still not that mom that i want
to be